TREVOR JOHNS: Hello.
Welcome to Android Developer
Office Hours
for October 17, 2012.
I'm pretty sure I have
that date right.
ALEX LUCAS: Yeah.
TREVOR JOHNS: Good.
Sorry for the delayed start.
For those of you who are
watching like, we've had a few
technical difficulties in
our studio this morning.
But we're ready to go.
So for those of you who are
joining us for the first time
this week, we're going to spend
the next 30 minutes or
hour or however long it takes
to go and answer your
questions on Android
development topics.
We have a Moderator queue,
where people have been
submitting questions
before the show.
We'll be going through
those questions.
But if you are watching live,
feel free to jump onto our
Google+ Hangout, where you
can go ahead and ask
us questions live.
And we'll go ahead and interleaf
live questions in
between the prerecorded
questions on Google Moderator.
So with that in mind, let's go
ahead and get started on the
first question on
Moderator today.
So this question is
from Australia.
And I think the name
there is J. Dixon.
You'll have to forgive me if
I got that name wrong.
"It seems impossible to query my
in-app purchase prices from
the store using the API.
Ideally, I want to display
localized prices for my in-app
purchases to my users.
How can I do this without
creating a lot of mess and
bundling prices for each--"
ALEX LUCAS: Each locale.
TREVOR JOHNS: --locale."
Thank you.
All right, so Alex, do you have
any thoughts on this one?
ALEX LUCAS: Unfortunately, from
what I remember, it's not
possible to query localized
prices.
Part of the reason for that is
the currency exchange rates
are constantly fluctuating, and
we don't want to create a
situation where you display one
price in your application,
and then when we go through
the purchase flow through
Google Play, the currency
exchange shift happens, and
they get charged
a higher price.
TREVOR JOHNS: Well, I think,
actually, you can record
per-country prices.
So if you are recording--
I think the old model would do
live currency conversion,
while in the new one, you set
all your prices for every
product simultaneously.
ALEX LUCAS: Right.
I think what they wanted--
at least from what I'm reading
from the question, they want
to set it once for one locale
and sort of pull in live data
on the price for each locale.
But like Trevor said, I think
what you can do is set the
price individually for each
locale, which is what I think
you'd have to do in this case.
If you want to create a
situation where you are
updating the price over time,
say, in-app gold or potions or
something cost $1, and you
want to drop to $0.50, or
however you want to do that,
what you would have to do then
is set the pricing up
on your own server.
And on an application start,
just have it ping the server,
check for new prices, display
within the app, or use
something like Google Cloud
Messaging to ping the
application whenever there's a
price change, and then it can
pull that data down
off the server.
TREVOR JOHNS: We do have a batch
upload API for prices.
So if you take all of your
prices in put them into a CSV
file, you can send those to
the Google Play Developer
console, and then you
can serve that
same CSV to your app.
And then they'd both
be working off the
same pricing data.
ALEX LUCAS: Yeah.
TREVOR JOHNS: All right.
So let's move on to
the next question.
This one is from Reto Meier,
our own Reto Meier here in
Mountain View, California.
We were going to go and try and
do a video question for
this, but I don't think it's
going to work too well.
So we're just going
to go ahead and--
unless Louis over here
wants to go and try
and pull it up live.
But I think we're just going to
go ahead and read this one
out this week.
So the question is, DicePlayer,
which was an app
that was featured last week,
actually, on one of the app
review shows, displays a pop-out
window, and it plays
video even when the app's
running in the background.
And you can sort of
drag it around.
It's actually a really
interesting effect, if you
want to go ahead and download
the app on your own to take a
look at it.
But the question is, "How
does that work?
And is it something that's
going to break in future
releases?" And I believe, Alex,
you found a library that
actually lets you do this.
ALEX LUCAS: Yeah, so there's
a library available.
It's an open-source library
called StandOut.
It's a third-party library that
lets you create little
floating windows you can drag
around on your home screen.
It's a pretty nifty-looking,
always-on-top functionality,
where you can even open other
apps, and the StandOut window
will sort of float
on top of it.
So this actually works--
so DicePlayer is using this
library, StandOut.
And StandOut actually
works by using the
system alert dialogue.
In terms of will this break
in future releases, we
can't say for sure.
But the system alert dialogue
wasn't designed
with video in mind.
So it's sort of an odd use of
the system dialogue, and I
wouldn't expect that to work
without some update perversion
from the developer
of the library.
Especially difficult would be
the context of actually using
it to play video the way
that DicePlayer does.
I expect that to break in all
sorts of corner cases unless
the developers have been
really careful about
that kind of thing.
For instance, playing a floating
video window on top
of an application that's
playing other video.
There's serious resource
allocation
considerations there.
TREVOR JOHNS: Yeah, I think that
pretty much covers it.
From a UI perspective,
it's definitely
an interesting effect.
But it's not really the Android
way of doing things.
ALEX LUCAS: Right.
Having a window that you can
drag around sort of breaks the
only in one application at a
time UI paradigm that we go
for with Android.
It is a neat effect, and the
StandOut library is impressive
in terms of what they've
accomplished.
But I would say it should
be used with care.
TREVOR JOHNS: Right.
Let's move on to our
third question.
So another question from
J. Dixon in Australia.
And so the question is, "With
in-app purchases on Google
Play, is there an easy way to
offer discounts for a Play
account across all of our
in-app purchases?
Or would I have to write
and manage this?"
So we don't really have
a way to go and--
actually, we really don't have
much of a way to offer
discounts, period.
You could go and upload a
different set of prices if you
were, say, applying discounts
to every in-app product in
your in-app catalog.
Just update all the prices.
It should take effect live.
But if you only want to target
one specific user, we really
don't have any way to
do that on our end.
You'd have to add some code into
your application, which
is responsible for selecting a
different in-app product based
on that user.
Now that said, I'm going to give
you a big caution here.
And that is part of reason why
we have the concept of an
in-app product and why you have
to upload all your prices
to the server is to make sure
that if somebody tampers with
your APK, they can't go and
purchase one product at a
different price.
Imagine that if we put the
prices into your application
as code, and you just sent them
to Google Play, it would
be trivial to go and find that
string and replace it with a
different price and then get
all your content for $0.99,
regardless of what you
want to buy it for.
So, in this case, it's a little
different in that
you're still using an
in-app product.
But if somebody discovers that
you're doing this, they could
just go and modify the APK to
go and select that different
product ID, regardless of
what user is actually
logged into the phone.
So from a security perspective,
this is a bit sketchy.
So that's the one thing I really
do want to warn you
about here if you do
decide to do this.
ALEX LUCAS: One alternative
might--
I don't know if this would work,
but just playing through
the scenario in my head, one
thing that might work is to
not store the item ID for the
discounted version of the item
on the device.
Just have it on your server and
have the user authenticate
to the server.
The server sends down the
discount item ID.
TREVOR JOHNS: Yeah,
that would work.
I mean, there is still a risk.
If somebody just finds that
product ID, there's nothing
stopping somebody from going
and plugging it in there.
But you'd have to actually
discover it exists.
ALEX LUCAS: Right.
You'd have to discover it
exists, and you'd have to
maybe mimic the user packets
for something to
get the item ID.
TREVOR JOHNS: Yeah, it is
obfuscation, and so all the
caveats that come
with that apply.
But if it's just a small
discount, you might not really
care that much.
And that being said, the
user is still going
to have to pay something.
So I don't think it's going
to be a big difference.
So let's see here.
"is there any way to do a route
between two points with
the Android Map API?" And this
is coming from Brazil.
So this is essentially driving
directions, I believe, in
which case the answer is if
you're using MapView, no.
But if you're using an intent
to fire-- to load Maps, I
believe it's possible by
just using a Maps URL.
ALEX LUCAS: I think so, yeah.
You could just fire an intent
with the destination--
TREVOR JOHNS: It's an
undocumented feature of Maps,
essentially.
But if you have a URL for
driving directions, like you'd
get from the desktop version
of Maps, there's a query
parameter for source address
and a query parameter for
destination address.
And if you fire off the intent
that looks just like the URL
built on the desktop, the Maps
application will offer to
intercept that and will
go and calculate
driving directions locally.
Again, not possible
with MapView, but
possible with an intent.
So this question is coming
from Andrew in Romania.
The question is, with Android
Awesome player, which is part
of the video framework, the
media playback framework,
they're getting an unexpected
abort prepare, notify listener
of error, which is preventing
them from playing an MP4.
They're getting this error on
Android 2.3.4, and it sounded
like it was across several
different devices, looking at
their Stack Overflow question.
And the file, also,
interestingly enough, it works
fine when they're playing
off of the SD card.
So that's really interesting.
Normally, when you see those
types of errors, it's because
you've encoded your video
to use the wrong format.
And I think in this case, what's
most likely happening,
if you look very carefully at
their source, they're actually
retrieving the file from
an HTTPS server.
I can't say this for sure
without actually having the
real URL, which is not present
in your question.
So if do have that, feel
free to ping us.
We can take a closer
look at it.
But my guess is it's probably
an SSL error, like the
certificate's not trusted.
ALEX LUCAS: But why would that
happen on the SD card and not
in the private search?
TREVOR JOHNS: No, if it's on the
SD card, there's no SSL.
ALEX LUCAS: Oh, OK.
So the other way around.
It works except on
the SD card.
TREVOR JOHNS: No, other
way around.
It works on the SD card.
It does not work when they
stream from their server.
ALEX LUCAS: OK, so it's an SSL
error, and they bypass SSL
because it's going
to the SD card?
TREVOR JOHNS: Right.
ALEX LUCAS: OK.
TREVOR JOHNS: Well, yeah.
That said, there's nothing
in the logs that actually
indicates this is
an SSL error.
This is just my best guess based
on the limited logs we
have available.
Again, if you can actually give
us the actual URL to the
file, we can do a little
bit more diagnostics.
But just based on the limited
information available, that's
our best guess.
Next question comes from
Ryan E. in Utah.
"I'm developing a resource app,
but I have partners that
only want to have the customers
use a specific
version until they've QAed
that application.
Is there any way to restrict
what version is downloaded
from Google Play?"
ALEX LUCAS: I'm a little
confused by what they mean by
resource app.
TREVOR JOHNS: Yeah, that was a
little unclear to me, too.
My guess is it's essentially an
APK that provides services
to other APKs.
So the example, like,
Open Table, right?
It has an intent that you
can fire off to go and--
actually, to go and make a
reservation, or actually quite
possibly something like
a theme, right?
It could be an APK that just
contains resources, which
actually would make sense.
And then they're going and
looking inside that to load it
to re-theme their app.
ALEX LUCAS: OK.
Interesting.
So to their question, "Is there
a way to restrict what
version is downloadable for
a given user?" Not really.
I mean, you can't say,
bob@gmail.com only gets to see
version 3 and not version
4, anything like that.
TREVOR JOHNS: Well, I think even
more generally, you can't
restrict the version, period.
When you download an app from
Google Play, you always get
the latest version.
ALEX LUCAS: Sort of.
You do have the option of
using a multiple APK.
And what that would let
you do is restrict per
user based on the--
like let's say the platform
version or
the size of the screen.
So what you would then do is
break your APK into like three
different versions.
For instance, let's call
them 9, 10, and 11.
And say Version 10 only works
with phone devices, and
Version 11 is compatible with
x large devices, which would
include tablets.
Then when the user went to
market, they would see Version
11 if they were on a tablet, and
they would see Version 10
if they were on a phone.
Multiple APKs, they don't work
for every situation.
They will only let you
restrict based on the
platform SDK on--
let's see, platform SDK, screen
size, and GL texture.
So you can't do a thing, like
I said before, like, say,
bob@gmail.com gets to see
Version 11, and everyone else
gets to see Version 10.
So it depends on what criteria
you would want to restrict on.
I'm guessing from the content of
the question that you would
want to restrict on the version
of the other app.
So the other version of
application A that's installed
on the user's system would
define what version of
application B was visible.
And that's not really
currently possible.
Google Play wasn't really
designed to work like that.
You would probably have to
either implement some sort of
very well-defined interface
between the two applications
and just test the living crap
out of it until you're
reasonably confident that you
can upgrade one of those
without breaking
the other one.
Or you would have to release
them in tandem or maybe have a
side loading thing where--
actually, no, I take
that back.
It is against the Google Play
TOC to have an application
that downloads other
applications.
So you wouldn't be able to
do anything like that.
It would really have to be
a very well-defined and
thoroughly tested interface
between the two applications.
TREVOR JOHNS: So just one
last reminder here.
We are getting to the end
of our prerecorded
questions for this week.
So if you have any questions
that you want to ask us live,
feel free to hop onto Google+.
Even if you don't have a
webcam, we can accept
questions via chat.
But you have about, probably,
two minutes before we're out
of questions, and we'll be
signing off for the day.
So this question comes from Andy
C. in Perth, Australia,
who says, "I have a requirement
to convert PCM
files to MPEG4 files.
Can we have some demo code for
MOD codec encoding, please."
That's a pretty big
question there.
You want to go and
convert from one
file format to another.
I don't think we have any
published sample code that
demonstrates how to do this.
ALEX LUCAS: No.
Generally, when we write sample
code and we publish
official Android sample code,
it's for general-purpose stuff
that's specific to the Android
framework, that there's a
reasonable assumption that a lot
of Android developers are
going to want, and it's
something specific to Android.
This is pretty independent of
the fact that it would be
running on Android.
Generally, what you would want
to do is find a good
transcoding Java library.
TREVOR JOHNS: They did mention
they'd looked at FFmpeg, which
is actually a pretty
good choice.
ALEX LUCAS: It is a
good choice, yeah.
TREVOR JOHNS: It's actually
LGPL licensed, too, so--
ALEX LUCAS: OK.
TREVOR JOHNS: Actually, I
believe it's dual licensed--
LGPL and GPL.
There were some licensing
concerns from the developer.
I'm afraid we can't actually
speak to those since we're not
legal experts.
But usually, LGPL is pretty
permissive of--
it's designed to be
used as a library.
So you can usually include
it in other code.
I think there were some cases,
depending on which codec you
used, the licensing
status changed.
ALEX LUCAS: From what I remember
with LGPL, the rule
was you could include
it with your code.
It wouldn't force you to GPL
your code if you didn't make
changes to the LGPL library.
TREVOR JOHNS: I think there are
some specific cases here
where it's only GPL licensed.
ALEX LUCAS: Oh, OK.
TREVOR JOHNS: So if you do use
FFmpeg, be a bit careful with
the license there.
The FFmpeg developers do have a
page dedicated to discussing
the license.
So they explained it
in great detail.
But outside of that, another
option you could do would be
to go and set up a web service
that's responsible for
transcoding.
That way, you just have a copy
of FFmpeg or whatever service
you need that'll do the
transcoding on your server and
then give back the
resulting file.
Which is actually an interesting
question there
because you're trading off
on-device CPU to do it versus
network bandwidth, right?
Does it make more sense to use
the device's limited CPU to do
the transcoding or to upload
it somewhere else
and have it do both?
Now, doing transcoding on the
device will waste battery.
But a lot of users also have
limited networking capability.
ALEX LUCAS: But also, depending
on the size of the
file, you could also burn
through the battery.
The issue with uploading and
then downloading is that you
would be paying the price
in bandwidth twice.
You'd only transcode once, but
you'd have to upload a giant
file and download.
TREVOR JOHNS: Yeah, I think
transcoding on the device
probably does make the
most sense here.
ALEX LUCAS: Probably.
I think with this kind of
question, I would say just run
some tests.
Part of it depends on
the common use case.
Like are you transcoding a
3-second video of a kitten
playing with a ball of yarn
or a full-length movie?
Because in different cases,
you're going to have different
ideal ways to handle them.
TREVOR JOHNS: Yeah.
And we still don't have anybody
on our live Hangout.
So with that, that's the end
of our questions for today.
Thank you to everyone
who wrote in.
We're here every Wednesday
at 2:00 PM Pacific time,
answering your questions.
Please, if you do have a
question, submit it to
Moderator ahead of time.
We can go and get you the best
answers if the questions don't
come in an hour before
the show.
Also, we're trying to
do something new.
We tried to do it with Reto's
video this week.
We'll be doing it next
week, as well, too.
Next week, we'll actually be
able to show the video.
But we want to go ahead and have
as many of the questions
in Moderator have videos
attached to them as possible.
So when you do submit your
questions, it's now a new
field in Moderator that says
"attach YouTube video," and
you just paste a URL to
a prerecorded video
from YouTube there.
It's not required.
You're still welcome to submit
questions the old-fashioned
way with text.
But if you do have a webcam and
want to take 30 seconds to
go and record your question,
we'd love to see
your face on the air.
So please give it a try.
And as always, let us
know how it works.
You can reach us via our Google+
page, which is Android
Developers, or
developers.android.com/+ is
the shortcut URL to get there.
And with that, I think that's
it for this week.
ALEX LUCAS: Yep.
TREVOR JOHNS: So thanks,
everyone, for joining us.
And again, we'll be back
next Wednesday.
Happy coding.